hope
great to meet you great to see you what
an absolute you know ride this season
has been yeah full of emotion full of
heart we have so much to get into are
you ready hey I'm ready to do it all
right you say you're ready okay well I
gotta know how are you feeling you know
being out of the house being in jury
I feel great right now I feel
I feel great
um
the house is it can be hard to have you
know before every comp you're nervous
your heart is racing Flags don't fall
like Fallout your body and your your
palms are always shaking you're not
scared but you're just something you
hear all the Whispers and turn around
and
I feel great right now I'm not hearing
any of that it's amazing
all right all right well
well you had any incredible moment where
y'all had like a synchronized dance
followed by a group hug
you tell me what that moment meant to
you listen I came on this show to leave
my mark you know the end goal was never
my goal my goal is to make sure like I
came on this show and I showed Canada
hey hopes your team for real I wanted to
share my story I want to share how
unique it was and I wanted to do
everything
in a way that no one's ever done before
you know so
I watch a show and people usually go cry
they hug they you know do a typical bye
everyone I'm like no no no we're not
gonna do that we're gonna do that hey
all right all right
ah nice okay well listen we also saw you
know there was another touching moment
where you were with Anika and Daniel C
and Koozie and you were celebrating the
diversity of the crown Alliance you know
you had a moment where you were speaking
in your own languages explain to me what
it was like to share a moment like that
um the best part about Big Brother
Canada is that you come with people that
you never thought you crossed packed
with Anika being from Bangladesh I never
thought I'd ever connect with she's
literally my best it's it's crazy and
cozy from Zimbabwe Jonathan from
Newfoundland and Daniel C standing for
everything that he stands for it um it
was an amazing group and she'd be able
to talk in my language or they'd give me
a sentence and I'd say it back I truly
felt like yo like I came from somewhere
DJ accepted me welcoming me with open
arms and I loved it that's why I love
the crown so much we're all different
and we all welcome each other
all right well listen we gotta talk a
little bit of strategy now just gonna
change again uh so listen time in The
veto hook himself off and you know if he
if he had kept you know this if things
have stayed the same this week were you
willing to
I guess
go through with your plan
so are you talking about if I won the
POV yeah sorry if you had won the POV
yeah what would your plan have looked
like so I know that I have the crown no
matter what happens I have Koozie I
didn't see you have Anika my plan was to
win the POV keep the mountains the same
and move on to next week next week would
have had the numbers it would have
literally been four against the three
girls and would have the numbers to
control all the votes and my job
obviously in the crown was literally to
be the performer someone that every comp
would get the power and the crown would
decide together what would do with it my
also role was also to be the shield they
gotta put himself on the Block keep the
knobs the same and send home whoever was
next to me and you know I failed I
didn't perform in the POV when it was
time to perform and this happened the
way it was because I just couldn't come
through and
it's all right you know I do my best and
that's how I can ask for it all right
well listen I gotta know when Claudia
was up there and said koozie's name to
go next to you what what were you
feeling in that moment
I knew it was rap I knew that it was my
time you know I knew right away that
like the crown was literally designed
for Queen Koozie you know when she
wanted to strike again Zach and she
called me into a room to make it happen
I knew that the crown was designed for
her and whatever koozie's targets were
and landed with everybody in the crown
so I had to take a bullet for my queen
you know I had to protect my queen and I
knew right away I was gonna go home
okay well we had we you know you had a
moment where you spoke with Anika and
Daniel C and you were claiming that
Koozie was planning to cut them both and
go to the finals with Ty yeah why did
you use that as your pitch for them to
keep you
I knew that if I came out of this game
and I'll put up a fight I'll be ready
for the rest of my life and the night
before that I could not sleep
I knew I'd hate myself the very next day
and
I was like you know what I came on this
show by myself and I've always been
putting everybody before me I think it's
time to play Big Brother but it was too
late and I already knew that I already
knew what the outcome was going to be
but I wanted to make sure like moving
forward I'll be able to look back and
say hey at least put up a fight I at
least try to play Big Brother you know
for myself
all right okay well how do you think
they received that pitch
um feeling what was what was the energy
I already knew when you're talking to
someone and you know the receiving thing
you know you know the answer
um and you was going nowhere but just
for myself my own well-being I wanted to
make sure that in my heart and my soul
that I put up a fight and that's exactly
what I did
I tried my best at the end of the day
and there's absolutely no one anything
there's nothing that anyone can say or
do that will make me feel like I didn't
try my best all right all right well you
know throughout the season you've worked
with different groups of people you know
you worked with the boys you worked with
the crown you worked with Santina which
Alliance do you feel benefited your game
the most
foreign
I had the sword I fell on top of the
world I won't play
and
I last saw that
um I think the crown
the crown was was the group that worked
best because there was no
dictatorship there was no leader there
was no one person orchestrating every
move I felt like everything we did
together was a unit and I learned a lot
of lessons from the crowd that I'm going
to take into real world
and I'm grateful for all of it so I love
this I love that you've learned some
lessons and that I I want to know more
about that what lessons do you feel like
you learned from this game that you want
to take with you throughout life
I learned that not everybody thinks the
way that you do not everybody feels the
way that you do and not everybody
expresses the emotions the way that you
do you know my whole life when I was
when I'm talking to people and they
don't feel excited or sort of the same
type of energy the way that I show it I
think something's wrong but that's not
true everybody grew up different
everybody came from a different came
from a different Walk of Life and they
expressed this differently you know so
you have to accept that and obviously
the last lesson I learned is that in
this world everybody is doing what's
best for them and you know just
everybody's after the grand prize or
whatever their goals are whatever they
can do to use and manipulate you to get
that to get to their goal they'll do it
so your best chance of surviving this
world is to do the exact same all right
all right well you know I I would love
to know if you have any regrets about
the way any of your alliances came to an
end I just want to know I just want to
find out
um my biggest regret and always will be
Santina and I'm not gonna lie
in that Split Second when I picked Anika
in the theater fees that that's that
felt like a lifetime to me
um that moment right there felt so long
because I was going through a different
outcomes all the different possibilities
and I knew that if I picked her moving
forward the crowd would not trust me
they would not be loyal to me anymore
because they knew they'll know that
Apple said before them but if I had
picked the crown
and since he was by herself it makes
sense
so when I picked the Nika I was I truly
believe that I thought Daniel would
maybe go her way that's why I picked
Anita too but
I see the pig Santina and should have
gave it to Daniel and then they'll be
given to Anika and
it would have worked out but again we
could not tell the future how do you
store for us and that is going to be my
biggest regret you know okay all right
well thank you for sharing that with me
I have to listen hope you might be out
of the house but you aren't out of the
game you are still in this game okay
what will you be looking for in a player
to make them worthy of your vote
um right now I'm not looking at anybody
except for the Memories in the crown and
if any of the crime members end up in
the final two that's who I'm cast my
ball to and if it's cool on there with
another crowd member
I'm sorry but my vote goes to Queen
all right okay all right so it's fair to
say that you are more of a you know a
fan of the social game than a strategic
or a bit of both
big brother it's not you know it's not
too much about
I think it's everything
there's so many different elements
there's so many different factors that
affect the show and it's not just about
winning comps it's not about coming up
with perfect strategies I think it's
truly about the connection and the team
that you have behind you
how much of an army can build up and you
know just take with you all the way and
because you did just that and I truly
believe in my heart that she is worthy
of winning and she stands for so much
people back in Africa and Africa are
going to be praising her name
and she wins it so that's where my board
is going all right all right well thank
you so much hope I mean
you are a part of the all-powerful jury
now and you still have so much of this
experience to enjoy so we can't wait to
see how it all turns out and welcome to
this big crazy Big Brother family
all right
thank you so much hope
to me thank you
thank you
laughs